Intentemos convertir el número 6 del
sistema decimal al sistema binario.
Te mostraré mi forma favorita de hacerlo.
Empezaremos por escribir rayas para los bits.
Empezaremos con 8 rayas que representan 8 bits o
un byte, aunque probablemente no las necesitemos
todas para convertir este número tan pequeño.
Después escribiremos los valores de todas las
posiciones: la primera posición o el primer bit es
la posición del 1, o de 2 elevado a la potencia 0,
el segundo bit es la posición del 2 o de 2
a la 1, el tercer bit es la posición del 4,
o de 2 al cuadrado, después tenemos
la posición del 8, la posición del 16,
solo estamos duplicando, la posición del 32, la
posición del 64, y la posición del 128. Bien,
ahora que tenemos estas posiciones empezaremos
desde la izquierda, miraremos las posiciones y
nos preguntaremos en cada una de ellas "¿es
este valor más grande que el valor del 6?"
128 es más grande que 6 así que pondremos un cero
aquí porque no necesitamos representar el valor
de 128 dentro de este pequeño número 6.
64 también es mayor que 6, 32 también es
mayor que 6, 16 también es mayor
que 6, 8 también es mayor que 6.
Así que hasta ahora tenemos un montón
de ceros, pero 4 no es mayor que 6,
así que finalmente pondremos uno. Ahora lo que
haremos es restar 4 de 6. 6 menos 4 es igual a 2.
Dos es el valor restante que todavía necesitamos
representar. Bien, vayamos a la siguiente posición
tenemos la posición del 2. 2 no es más grande
que 2, de hecho es exactamente igual a 2,
así que también pondremos 1. Y una vez
más, restamos dos dedos lo cual es cero,
2 menos 2 es cero y ya no hay nada más
que representar. Ya hemos representado
completamente el valor del 6. Eso significa
que podemos poner 0 en esta posición restante.
Ahora podemos decir que esta es la forma
de representar el 6 en binario. El byte
completo se ve así o podemos acortarlo a 4 bits
y escribir 0110, o tal vez acortarlo a solo 3
bits y escribir 110, pero normalmente preferimos
presentar los bits en grupos de cuatro o de ocho.
Bueno, ahora intentemos con
un número más grande así que
borremos todo lo que tenemos por aquí y
mantengamos los valores posicionales ya
que nos serán útiles y van a ser iguales.
Simplemente vamos a borrar todo lo demás.
Bien es suficiente ahora
intentemos con el número 25.
¿Cómo convertimos el número 25 del sistema
decimal al sistema binario? Bueno, empecemos
de nuevo. ¿Es 128 más grande que 25? Sí, lo es,
así que ponemos un 0, 64 es más grande que 25,
ponemos un 0, 32 es más grande, entonces pondremos
un 0, pero 16 no es más grande que 25, así que
16 cabe en 25, por lo tanto pondremos un 1.
Y hacemos una pequeña operación para saber
cuánto nos falta por representar. 25 menos
16 es igual a... es igual a 9, por lo tanto,
todavía necesitamos representar el valor
de 9 en estos bits restantes, ¿cierto?
El siguiente valor posicional es la posición del
8, 8 no es mayor que 9, eso significa que vamos
a necesitar usar esta posición. Ponemos
un 1 y restamos: 9 menos 8 es igual a 1,
y por lo tanto todavía tenemos una cosa más, un 1
que representar. Hasta ahora hemos representado el
24 justo aquí, ¿cierto? Aquí estamos representando
el 24. Si llenamos el resto de ceros tendríamos el
número 24, pero estamos buscando el 25, así que
seguimos adelante. ¿Es 4 más grande que 1? Sí,
entonces pondremos un 0, 2 es más
grande uno, entonces ponemos un 0,
y 1 es igual a 1, así que pondremos un 1 aquí.
Así que aquí tenemos el número 25 del sistema
decimal en binario, que requirió de
1 2 3 4 5 bits. Así que probablemente
queremos representarlo en un byte, justo así.
Y bueno esta es la estrategia básica que uso
para convertir números del sistema decimal al
sistema binario. Usando estos 8 bits podemos
representar números hasta el 255, más allá de
eso se necesitarán más bits, y honestamente,
a partir de aquí lo mejor es usar una
calculadora o escribir un programa para hacerlo.